foreign
thanks for taking my call you bet how
can we help today Emily
hi I'm trying to get prepared for
college savings I have a three-year-old
and a kid on the way
and my husband and I both went to very
expensive schools and kind of looking at
the six percent growth and tuition year
over year the total amount to save is
very high
and I'm curious if you know I loved for
my kids to have scholarships and
everything but I want to be prepared for
a worst case scenario
and I'm curious if there's any scenario
where you'd recommend putting some of
that Savings in something other than a
529
what do you mean by other than where
else would you put it are you
considering
I guess I'm just it
you know
you know that money and I'm curious if
there's any benefit or recommendations
for not getting that 10 percent
well even if you get a scholarship
what's really cool about these plans is
you can withdraw against that
scholarship so if let's say there's a
twenty thousand dollar scholarship and
you go well now I didn't need this money
well you can withdraw 20 000 from that
savings account tax-free
okay so that doesn't need to be a
concern and there's broad application
into how you can use those funds when we
talk about learning and education it's
very room and board the laptops the
books are so much regardless of where
there's trade schools
certifications you know talk about
online you know technology programs like
Bethel Tech which I endorse I mean
listen they can go a lot of different
ways it's not like you're trapped is
that what you're feeling okay
I'm just it seems like a lot of money to
sit in effect 29 so I wasn't sure if it
well how much money are you talking put
something
well
where I went to school if I was
projecting that for my daughter it'd be
just shy of 800k when she's what okay
that's crazy I'm a little short of
breath why does she need to go there 800
why does anyone need to go there where
is she going
it's just it's like a top tier school I
I mean I don't know if she will but I
would love to be able to provide please
tell okay how much did you pay for it
because I'm now I'm very curious yeah
well I had need-based scholarships but
the full rate when I went to school was
about 40K a year okay that sounds a lot
more reasonable compared to 800k for
four years
yeah and they today's rate is like 80k
okay can I ask you a question can I ask
you a question I really and I'm okay if
it's different than what I think but I'm
curious to know you said you and your
husband both went to very expensive
schools
okay
do you think that those schools were
worth the tuition based on where you
guys are now
and maybe where you could have gone to
school
I believe so and my husband got a full
he he did Roxy so he did he got a full
scholarship so he didn't end up paying
but
um I believe it was worth it if if my
daughter wanted to go but you didn't but
either sounds like neither one of you
paid full tuition or anything close
correct correct yeah I gotta tell you I
I I just want to challenge you on name
brand schools
um let me put it this way
uh you remember the last time you went
to the doctor I mean you're getting
ready to have a baby so remember your
last checkup
yeah yeah at any point in your medical
Journey when you were getting baby
checkups or your own personal health
have you ever asked your doctor
to bring their diploma in and show you
their diploma
no why
uh I don't know
yeah so how in the world would you trust
the life of your baby with this Doctor
Who you don't even know where he went to
med school in undergrad
right all right you get where I'm going
here
I'm not anti-education Emily but I'm
telling you nobody cares
nobody cares where you went to school
uh education important for the
qualification you need yes notice I said
for the qualification that you need and
your kids the landscape of education is
changing so rapidly that by the time
your kids are there the 529 is the
safest play just give you an idea right
now okay so enrollment is down
tremendously
ten percent I mean uh uh I just put this
out there I gotta look it up uh but
enrollment is down so much right now in
the United States and and it's gen Z so
this is the generation right now that's
in high school and they're looking at
this stuff and just to give you the
numbers College Roman is down nearly 10
over the last two years only 51 percent
of gen Z teens are considering a
four-year degree that's a 20-point drop
since May of 2020. the point is there's
a lot of Education options that aren't
going to look like they look right now
and so I think the 529 George the point
I'm making is whether I'm right or wrong
and what I predict it gives her
flexibility oh yeah and one other thing
Emily if you put that money elsewhere it
is going to have a tax burden on it and
so if you put it in the 529 it goes in
tax-free grows tax-free you can withdraw
it tax-free you can also change the
beneficiary and it's very loose this
could be spouse this could be in-laws it
could be children including step
children foster children siblings step
siblings nieces nephews Aunts Uncles
first cousins so the options are endless
this money is not going to go to waste
and I assume you guys have an amazing
household income can you tell me what it
is
I think it's around 500k there we go
okay and so here's the thing by the time
they're 16 17 they start applying to
colleges yeah you guys could could cash
flow this as well yeah right very easily
maybe yeah I don't know by the time
they're going to college you're going to
be completely debt free including the
house right if you're not already right
and so at that point making 500 000 this
is a rhetorical question by the way
could you cash flow College the entire
audience listening is screaming yes
trust me you can
right you couldn't cash flow 80k a year
making 500 000.
oh no I could yeah definitely there we
go okay so I still would do the 529.
that will look like because
strategically it's a smart move to
invest with that kind of tax advantage
and you can always change the
beneficiary you can withdraw against the
scholarship there's so many options
there and then a worst case scenario
when you can withdraw it it's going to
create you know income tax and there's a
10 penalty but that is a worse worse
worst case scenario and there's a lot of
things you can do with that money yeah
and then there's the fact that your kid
may show up one day at 16 17 and go hey
I want to do this I know I want to do
this and this is how I can go do this
and it has nothing to do with a
four-year degree and the fancy college
that you went to that you'd like your
kid to go to parents we got to wake up
and sometimes those fancy colleges are
more about our desires than theirs whoa
there it is Ken
well it is
okay now I'm fired up here's one more
for you college degrees have become more
about status than actual success and
that's the reality and uh the landscape
is changing so I say all that to say
investing in a 529 for Relevant
education
is the way to go George you laid it
right beautifully preach it and my
goodness everybody but the household dog
is uh it's amazing Fido might be on
there who knows yeah we'll dig into that
on the commercial why college is the
future